Once upon a time there was no sun, no solar
system, no us.
Just a cloud of gas and dust, a solar
nebula.
We are here today because billions of years
ago there was a nebula containing all the
necessary ingredients.
Everything that we see in our solar system
today that was all part originally of the
cloud of gas and dust.
That was our solar nebula.
Almost 5 billion years ago, a solar nebula
was prepared to give birth to our sun.
So we have billions of years ago our solar
nebula cloud of gas and dust.
And it's hanging out, but it's unstable.
What tips the balance to turn a cloud of gas
into solid objects.
Something has to change inside a nebula.
Something has to trigger the formation of
stars and planets.
And that remains a mystery.
So what's the answer to this 5 billion year
old mystery?
There are two theories.
Both start with fossils.
Fossils that make their way from the edge of
the solar system towards Earth.
Break through our atmosphere.
And find their way to us.
Meteorites are really important for us to
understand and study because they're time
capsules to when the solar system was
basically first forming.
Meena Wadhwa curates one of the largest
collections of meteorites on the planet.
These rocks hold a pristine record of the
very early history of the solar system.
There was nothing else around in the solar
system before these rocks were formed.
There was no earth.
There were no other planets.
It's mind blowing.
The first solid objects form out of a cloud
of dust surrounding our newborn star.
Asteroids and meteorites forming at the same
time contain the chemical fingerprint of our
solar nebula.
They actually contain some of the oldest
materials oldest solids that condensed from
the cloud of gas and dust as our solar
system was forming.
And so they came together and formed this
this big rock that you see here.
In 2017.
Researchers analyzing the composition of a
type of rocky meteorite called Chondrites
find a clue about how our solar system was
formed.
There might be, in fact, a smoking gun
somewhere in the chemistry of these rocks
that could tell us about what exactly
happened and how our solar system was formed.
This smoking gun is a radioactive element
called Iron 60.
And it's thought to be created only in
supernovas.
If you have a nebula which is about ready to
start forming stars and a supernova goes off
next to it, that supernova is going to dump
all those heavy elements into that gas cloud.
But it's also going to trigger the formation
of stars by slamming into that gas and
compressing it.
A nearby star goes supernova, the shockwave
strikes our solar nebula, injecting it with
Iron 60.
But the collision starts a runaway
gravitational collapse in the core of the
nebula. The gas cloud clumps together
becoming hot and dense.
Our sun is born.
As the sun is forming, there's basically a
cloud of junk all around the sun.
And as it orbits the sun, it kind of
accretes or sticks together and grows into
these balls.
Over the next hundred million years, these
balls get bigger and bigger, forming
asteroids, moons and planets.
All of the planets in our solar system seem
very different.
Some ice giants, some gas giants, some rocky
bodies.
But in fact, all of these planets came from
the same Presolar Nebula.
And on one small planet, the right cocktail
of elements gave rise to us.
Everything, every atom in our bodies was once
part of the Presolar Nebula.
The theory that a supernova nudged our solar
system into existence is compelling.
But not everyone agrees.
Sometimes the biggest arguments among
scientists are caused by the littlest things.
And in this case, I'm talking about little,
tiny radioactive atoms.
In 2017, studies reveal other meteorites
contain a different radioactive signature a
rare isotope of aluminum called aluminum.
26.
That's a rather odd atom that is not formed
very easily in supernovas.
So that had to come from somewhere else.
That somewhere else is a rare type of giant
star, 40 to 50 times the mass of our sun.
A wolf rayet star.
Stars can be very weird, and the very massive
stars are incredibly weird.
The largest type of star that we've seen is
what's known as a Wolf-Rayet star.
Wolf Rayet stars burn the hottest of all
stars, producing heavy elements like aluminum
26 during their short lives.
These are massive and hot and luminous, and
they blow off a tremendous wind.
This stellar wind ejects tons of matter from
the star into the surrounding space, creating
a bubble structure.
Scientists see this process at work in the
bubble nebula 7000 light years from Earth.
In the middle of the nebula is one of these
giant stars with a massive stellar wind.
High energy particles, radiation.
And just like the name suggests, it's
blowing a bubble in the larger nebula around
it.
The walls or shell of the bubble are dense
and full of matter.
The stellar wind pushes more and more matter
into the shell until this material collapses
under its own gravity and condenses into
stars.
It's entirely possible that what we're seeing
in the bubble Nebula is what happened here
four and a half or more billion years ago to
form the sun and the planets.
If our solar system formed within a
Wolf-Rayet bubble nebula, it would explain
why so much aluminum 26 is present in
meteorites.
But the jury is still out.
What we do know is that our story began with
the collapse of the solar nebula.
But one day our star will die.
Will the sun turn into a stunning nebula, or
will it just fade to black?